fly into a Marc Chagall painting from
your bed or sink into the tragedy of
malaise of philia with ingredients from
your kitchen from Edvard Munch
to Michelangelo social media users are
giving art classics a quarantine
makeover
the Russian Facebook group is a is
Olesya for art isolation started as a
challenge between friends in Moscow just
a few weeks later it has nearly half a
million members from all over the world
but no one expected such a huge reaction
that's for sure the group grew so
quickly right away people are really
taking time for this
going through artworks looking at the
websites of international museums to
find the right picture for themselves
and their families the rules of the
group are simple use a classic like this
Leonardo da Vinci painting take the
photo at home and use props that you
happen to have lying around in
quarantine Photoshop is not allowed I
decided to take part in the art
isolation project because I'm sick of my
cat and she's sick of me why did I take
part in this project because it is
uniquely wildly joyful and it gives
everyone positive emotions it gives you
a break from the difficult situation we
are all in users say many of the
recreations are a spontaneous thing but
some people have been sewing costumes
and getting the whole family involved
including their pets
now there are around 2,000 new posts
every day according to the page
administrators each one is a glimpse
into how self isolation can sometimes
open up new doors or draws to creativity
well now to a story that is inspiring
people around the United Kingdom and
Beyond a 99 year old Army veteran has
raised the equivalent of over 14 million
euros for the health service after
completing 100 laps of his garden
captain Tom Moore had initially set a
target of around a thousand euros in an
effort to thank health service staff for
the care that he had received for a
broken hip and cancer more than 600,000
people have donated